so instead of inches feet and miles
we're gonna be metric okay look what are
the four there are four and you all know
all of them what are the four units of
length the main important ones anyway
not like the really mini microscopy ones
and a super ridiculously long one what
are they on four important ones in the
metric system so I want to start us off
you can now write slash draw this with
me let's do centimeters okay
another one I would write above and
below it actually what's not two
centimeters just meters and there's one
more that we would use frequently
kilometers that's right yeah yeah I know
so as I mentioned if you were listening
about 45 seconds these are the ones that
we can bedrock so you need a skinny
where is even kilometers I mean we did
it recently so you guys know these are
the these are the four main units that
we're going to be talking terms on okay
so how do we move between them well the
metric system makes it super easy it's
not like 24 of this or 6080 of that for
instance if you have one kilometer for
example one kilometer okay how do you
turn from a kilometer into meters okay
no hold on what is whisk you actually
stand for you know what it means a
thousand right so kilometres literally
means thousand meters so if I say one
kilometer it means so to go from here to
here this is going to be 1,000 meters so
the number is actually x
oh yeah we I'm kind of going for biggest
to smallest all right so that was one
clue enough 1000 meters okay let's go
again meanest Isetta means well how many
centimeters are there in a me no answer
100 just like there are a thousand
meters in the club so you multiply it by
100 right so one kilometer is 1000
meters which is also a hundred thousand
centimeters is that okay this is one
kilometer that we started with all right
formal type how many millimeters in a
centimeter so going this way multiply by
ten so now if I ask the question how
many millimeters are they Uniqlo it up
the answer would be will I add another
zero dunno which would give me a million
okay cool
by the way sorry this is not very clear
all of the unit's here
they're a little lowercase now if you've
already opened up to page 119 okay it
starts off pretty basic I reckon you can
do question one without any cup on my
own okay on your own rather for question
two is where they're actually like
problems that require some fault okay so
for instance let's read questions
through together you want to go that way
blue ribbon is software dollar ten per
meter what's the cost of three hundred
and fifty centimeters of this ribbon
okay so let me just quickly write down
with you and I suggest you do this as
well this is question
what do you think what does it matter
anyway question she says when we say a
dollar ten per meter was it is that what
it says dollar ten okay and then they
say how much will that cost for 357
meters okay so I think it's really handy
I mean especially the beginning later on
you won't need to write this out but
it's a super useful problem solving
strategy to get all the important bits
of information down in front of you
like we depends it helps you process it
in your head the first thing we want to
do is this kind of thing this is what we
were doing here was conversions okay
converting between units so see how I've
got this in 357 that's how much I want
okay but the units they give us are not
in centimeters
they're in meters okay so what I'm going
to do is turn 350 centimeters into the
units that I need right so I want 350
centimeters and I want to eat meters
okay now have a look here right we were
going from kilometers to meters to
centimeters to millions from big to
small but here want to go the other way
only go from centimeters to meters
that's from here to here how am I gonna
do it yeah oh you've already calculated
well how how am I going to I heard it
here instead of multiplying I'm gonna
divide all right what should i / same
number that I have here divided by which
by the way it's the same deal all the
way through right you know I've got
plumbers coming you have a look at my
mastery because getting you shower and
that kind of thing and they're like are
nine hundred mill this there's a meal
that I'm like okay hold on what units
are they talking about they're all
talking you milliliters so if I wait
millimeters to centimeters I would again
I would divide by
whatever number I had before right 10
and here if you just carry the patent
okay mix it so which one am i interested
in set of meters 2 meters so I divide by
100 350 divided by hundred that's how
many meters little bit what is 350
divided by hundred so if that's how much
I actually want I can then say therefore
the cost will be how many meters times
how much you cost for each meter which
it must be 10 $3 85 you don't som want
to check that on there so check out yeah
happy does anyone can do and check for
me with their calculator 385 great ok so
most of the questions in this I mean
we're kind of revising this right it's
just those two steps there'll be some
conversion involved yeah okay
and then after that I can't solve the
problem bring it into whatever kind of
information you need